CHRISTA ESSIG: Hi, everybody.
Thank you so much
for joining us today.
We're really excited
about the panel
we have in celebration
of "Go Beyond the Grain."
So what is "Go
Beyond the Grain?"
And just a little bit of
background-- the Google food
team does a campaign every
year on whole grains.
And this year, in celebration
of the Year of the Pulse,
we've included pulses.
So we're going
beyond just grains.
And we want to talk about how
good grains and pulses are,
not only for your
body and health
but also for the
environment, and also how
they can be really delicious.
So this panel is a
perfect representation
of tying that all together.
And with us today, we have Minh
Tsai from Hodo Soy Beanery.
This is Minh.
And he will talk about the
culinary side and how delicious
soy and pulses can be.
And then we have Liz Carlisle,
author of "Lentil Underground."
She'll talk a lot about
the history of and
including into food systems
in general, and sustainable
agriculture, and how
pulses and lentils really
are a big supporter of
sustainable agriculture
and in support of a
healthy ecosystem.
And then Larry Kushi is a
nutritional epidemiologists
with Kaiser Permanente
and is here--
will talk a little bit
about the health benefits.
So without further delay,
I'm going to pass it
on to our panel leader, Liz.
And thanks everybody
for joining us.
And thanks so much to our
speakers for being here.
LIZ CARLISLE: Thank
you so much, Christa.
And thanks for all of you
taking your time here,
present with us in the
room and then remotely,
to talk about the
wonders of pulses.
So probably we should start
with a really basic issue, which
is what is a pulse, right?
We're not talking about this.
We're talking about a food.
So here in the group
assembled here,
who can tell me what a pulse is?
[LAUGHTER]
This is why you came, right?
This isn't a word we
use very much in the US.
This is more of a European term.
But it means the edible
seed of a legume.
Now that begs the
question, what is a legume?
So these are plants in
the bean and pea family.
And they share a
really important
botanical characteristic that
actually makes a big difference
for sustainability
and for health.
But the reason we're
talking about it today
and the reason we're using this
somewhat unfamiliar term pulse
is because, as
Christa said, the UN
has declared 2016 the
International Year of Pulses.
Why does the United
Nations care about pulses?
And why do they want
people to be aware of them?
Two main reasons--
one of them has
to do with environmental
sustainability.
And one of them has to
do with human health.
So first on environmental
sustainability--
and here I'm going to show
you for a minute this slide.
All right, so here
we have this graph
from the Environmental
Working Group
showing the carbon footprint
of various common foods
in the American diet.
So why do we see
these pulse crops
near the bottom of this graph?
So you see very low
carbon footprint
associated with things like
lentils, tofu, dry beans.
All of these are pulse crops.
All of these are legumes.
Well, let's start with something
that's a little bit more
common in terms of
the way we think
about environmental
health and what we eat.
So anybody here
trying to eat locally
for environmental reasons?
Yeah.
So lots of different reasons
you might eat locally-- you
might want to support
local farmers.
You might want to support
wonderful local businesses.
You might want to get
to know your farmer.
It might be about
relational eating.
But we also have this notion
of the carbon footprint
of our food having something
to do with food miles,
how far it's traveled.
So a group of researchers
looked into this.
And they found that actually
only about 4% of the greenhouse
gas emissions associated with
the average American diet come
from transport to
final point of sale.
That's the metric that we know
as food miles-- only about 4%.
In contrast, 83% of
emissions happen before food
leaves the farm gate.
Much of these emissions
are associated
with livestock production and
then also nitrogen fertilizer.
So why nitrogen fertilizer?
Well, it takes a
lot of fossil fuel
to make synthetic
nitrogen fertilizer.
And so the question is, is there
an alternative to livestock
production and using
all this fertilizer?
And the answer is yes.
And that's what we've
been doing for most
of agricultural history.
We've only had this
synthetic fertilizer
since the early 20th century.
Farmers have only
been using that since
about the mid 20th century.
And what people did before
that is they had these plants,
these leguminous plants,
that could pull nitrogen out
of the atmosphere, where
it's extremely abundant,
and then work with
bacteria in the soil
to convert that nitrogen
into a plant available form,
into fertilizer,
and not only use it
for their own fertility-- we'll
come back here for a moment
to the graph, yes, but also for
the fertility of the following
crop.
So they would leave
this nitrogen fertilizer
in the ground so that
the following crop
would have access to it.
So this was an alternative
to chemical fertilizer.
And it's been accessible
to farmers for all
of agricultural history.
So this is a way to
get out of the carbon
footprint of the livestock
system, the carbon footprint
of nitrogen fertilizer.
So it means that legume crops
and legume based pastures,
so pulses and their
pasture crop friends,
use the 35% to 60%
less fossil energy
than chemically
fertilized grains.
So to go back to
the graph, that is
why the carbon footprint of
these pulses, of these legumes,
is so low and why they're
so important for sustainable
agriculture.
And that's just one of the
many environmental reasons.
They're putting fertility
back in the ground.
They're helping
build soil health.
They're absolutely
critical to a food
system that's sustainable
in environmental terms.
They're also critical
to human health
and to a food system in
which all people have access
to sufficient, healthy,
culturally appropriate food.
So I'm going to move
to the next slide here.
I work with lentil farmers.
Why am I so excited
about lentils?
Well, I come from Montana.
Grain agriculture has been
the norm there for some time.
And for all the reasons we just
talked about environmentally,
lentils are the key to
making that grain agriculture
system sustainable.
And that's just one
legume in one place.
So this is true of other
legumes in other places.
The genius of this relationship
between grains and legumes
is not just about the
nutrition of the soil
or about environmental
health, but also
very much about human health.
So you're going to hear
some great examples later
from Larry.
But I want to talk
just a little bit
about lentils and some things
that I have learned since I
started working on them.
So you probably know
that these crops
are really high in protein.
You might know about fiber.
So lentils offer
more than a third
of the recommended intake of
fiber in a half cup portion.
But these pulse crops are also
really high in micronutrients.
So a half cup serving
of lentils provides
45% of recommended
daily folate, which
is necessary for the production
of red blood cells and protein
metabolism.
You've probably heard
it's important for women
of childbearing age
because of its role
in the developing embryo.
Also a cup of
lentils has potassium
comparable to a
banana-- potassium
important for electrolyte
and fluid balance
as well as muscle
and cardiac function.
And this one was probably
the most surprising to me--
antioxidants.
So I would normally
think of something
like blueberries or acai.
But it turns out
that lentils actually
have 56% more antioxidant
capacity than blueberries.
So these are these
nutrition-packed foods
that have been really
important staples
for working people for all
of agricultural history
more or less.
And then the other
thing-- so we talked
about environmental health.
We talked about human
health and public health.
But they're also totally
delicious, right?
These crops that have
been used for all
of agricultural history.
So they have 10,000, some
archeologists 18,000 years,
of culinary traditions
associated with them
from all over the world.
So on that note, I want to
transition to our next speaker.
And I want to tell you a
little bit about his story too.
So we're going to hear
now from Minh Tsai, who's
the founder, director,
CEO of Hodo Soy.
And Minh, as a child
in Vietnam, often
took morning strolls
with his grandpa
to the neighborhood tofu shack.
The freshness and
artisanal quality
of the soy milk, tofu,
and yuba of his childhood
eluded Minh for many
years when he came here
to the United States.
But finally in 2004,
he founded Hodo Soy
with the simple mission
of crafting the highest
quality, best tasting, freshest
soy milk, tofu, and yubs--
tofu skins-- possible.
These days, Minh remains
actively involved
in the production and innovation
of tofu as well as being
tofu's ultimately ambassador
by working with the chefs,
teaching tofu craft
and educating,
culinary students to
grow the next generation
of tofu officionados.
Before becoming
Hodo's tofu master,
Minh spent 10 years in strategic
consulting and finance.
And he graduated from
Columbia with a BA and masters
in economic development.
Minh--
MINH TSAI: Thanks, Liz.
I haven't had that formal
introduction for a long time.
It sounded kind of funny.
Because these days,
I'm a tofu maker.
My name is Minh Tsai.
If you don't know me, it's OK.
Because you're eating
my tofu at Google.
In fact, our tofu is in all
your campuses in the West coast
as well as in the East Coast
and other parts of the country
as well.
The reason I really
enjoy these types
of forum with Liz
and Larry, who's
going to come on later and
talk about health-- so I get
to talk about the food part.
Because usually when I give
a talk by myself, you know,
I'm somewhat of a hack when
it comes to all the data
that Liz talks about and a
hack in all the health part
that Larry talks about.
So now I have all the support.
Before I start, I'm going
to play you a video.
It's called "Tofu Disrupt."
It's an event that
we've done recently.
And I'll play the
video, and then I'll
come back to it to talk
about how we get people
to eat more pulses, more beans.
But essentially, the
video is a series
of event called Tofu Disrupt.
And the idea behind it is
to really educate people
about beans and in this
case, tofu in particular.
Tofu has a really short history
in America, less than 50 years,
relative to its
history in Asia, which
is several thousand years.
So in our education, we
basically want people not just
to understand the history of
where tofu comes from, but also
how we in the US use tofu
and how the use of tofu
really change our perception
and taste of tofu.
So I assume many
of you eat tofu.
That's why you're at this event.
And you eat beans.
But tofu wasn't really
consumed very much
here by the American
public until the late 70s.
And the reason for
that is because tofu
was introduced here by the
Japanese and the Chinese
more than 100 years ago.
But it remains in the
enclave, you know,
in the Chinatown
and the Japan Town.
The reason for that is
because there was very little
interaction, like, American--
the public doesn't really
go into Chinatown
grocery store to shop.
That's one reason.
But the second reason is tofu
is one of these food that's
not really packaged.
You know, we're so
used to packaged food.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Wrap the bean curd
like prize cheese.
[LAUGHTER]
So for me, I wanted
tofu to be a canvas
for really innovative chefs.
And that's why we
have these events.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
My name is Minh Tsai.
And I'm a tofu maker.
Growing up in Vietnam,
my grandfather
would take me to the tofu shack
where we bought freshly made,
delicious tofu every day.
The memory of that
tofu was my inspiration
for starting Hodo
Soy 10 years ago.
At Hodo, we treat tofu making
as both an art and a science.
Our focus is on making the
highest quality tofu possible.
So we start with
the best organic,
US grown soybeans we can find.
We select beans with a specific
protein and fat content
to produce what we believe
is the ideal mouth-feel
and flavor.
We soak the soybeans
overnight and then grind
and cook them to extract
the rich soy milk.
To this, we add a traditional
mineral coagulant.
Then we hand wrap the bean
curd like prize cheese
and press it into a variety
of textures, soft and firm.
The result is tofu that's
creamy, nutty, and rich.
But making delicious
tofu and yuba
is only one part of what we do.
At Hodo, we're also
educators and ambassadors
of all things tofu.
We want to disrupt
the pervasive idea
that tofu is just an ingredient
in Asian food or a bland meat
substitute.
So I started a series of
events called Tofu Disrut.
Well, welcome to Hodo.
We're going to do a quick tour.
Come on in.
My mission is to take
chefs on a deeper dive
into the art and
science of tofu--
So anybody want to make tofu?
--to show them
the transformation
from beans to liquid,
from liquid to solid,
and how this process influences
tofu's various textures
and flavors.
And then press it down.
-[INAUDIBLE] the box does that.
-This is where the
muscle comes in, guys.
Take this off.
There you go.
-I want to reveal the
true versatility of tofu
as a canvas on which to
create a supporting a player
or a delicious star ingredient.
-All right.
-Tofu Disrupt is meant to
inspire the chefs to create
entirely new dishes
that highlight
tofu's wide range of flavors
and textural profiles.
-So I chose to do this dish
and use the okara, which
is normally, as
Minh told us today,
given to farms for animals.
So we started trying to
make porridge with it.
And then we started smoking it
and adding onions and garlic,
and I feel came up with a pretty
tasty product with something
that is normally discarded.
-I'm Moroccan in heritage.
So I kind of went a
North African route.
And I fell in love with the
nama yuba was just like mind
blowing.
The other day I tasted it.
And I was like, wow, this
is an amazing product.
-I did a parsnip
cooked in soy milk.
I'm serving with a parsnip cake.
-I wanted to use the firm
tofu and incorporate it
in a very traditional Filipino
dish, which is pork adobo.
-I wanted to think
of a dish that
would mimic the textures of
burrata, so some fresh soy
milk, coagulating it.
That's all going to be
encased in a sheet of yuba.
-My goal is to redefine tofu as
a complex, cuisine-transcending
ingredient.
To do that, I want to
reacquaint chefs with tofu that
is deeply traditional, expertly
crafted, and a foundation
for culinary innovation.
At Hodo, we believe the
possibilities for tofu
are endless.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
MINH TSAI: What
do you guys think?
That looked pretty good, right?
We just did one in New York.
I just came back.
And it was a bigger
event than the one
we did in San Francisco.
But the reason we did
these Tofu Disrupt events,
it's really to not
just educate the public
but also to educate chefs.
You know, I was
talking earlier about
how tofu was introduced here
less than 50 years ago even
though it was already
in the Chinese
and the Japanese enclaves
50 years before that.
When tofu was
introduced to the US,
it was very much
introduced as a vegetarian
food, a food that would save our
planet from over-consumption.
And I believe in that.
I believe tofu can be a
great vegetarian food that
will save our planet, not just
from an ecological standpoint,
but also from the
health standpoint.
But for me, the fact that it
was so-- it was introduced
so narrowly as a vegetarian
food and more importantly,
as a meat substitute, was really
a wrong introduction, you know?
Because the people who
introduced tofu to America
as a meat substitute
really didn't
understand the chemistry and
the culinary aspect of tofu.
So for about 40, 50
years, we Americans
end up eating tofu that's
firm or extra firm.
And, you know, it's not
very tasty that way.
And then we also never
invested the time
to educate the chefs
on how to use the tofu.
So instead of growing,
tofu basically
remained more or less
just this mystery food
that's not very tasty.
I mean, I'm sure some of you may
have had it from your parents,
from your grandparents.
And you probably
thought, I'm probably
never going to eat this again.
So our goal at Hodo
for the last 10 years
is, yes, we want to
tell you that tofu
is really healthy and very
different from soy protein
isolate and all the
mock meat out there.
But we also want to
tell you that put
in the right hand, our
hands, or a chef's hand,
and in some cases in your hands
now, tofu can be delicious.
You know, people will
eat it if it's delicious.
So our mission is to
craft a high quality
ingredient for chefs to
make it more delicious.
But we also have
a line of products
that you can find in the
grocery stores that are selling
like hotcakes, you know?
We just recently
launched a Mapo tofu.
And Mapo tofu is the third
most popular Chinese dish
in any restaurant.
And we just launched
one just last week.
And it's really out-selling
everything else.
Why?
It's because it tastes good.
It's because the
ingredient is good.
LIZ CARLISLE: Well, thank you.
I think Minh has convinced you
that you want to eat pulses.
You definitely want to eat tofu.
And I think Larry
will convince you
that you not only want to do
this because it's delicious,
but you're doing
yourself a favor as well.
So Lawrence H Kushi is
director of scientific policy
at the Kaiser Permanente
Northern California
division of research.
Prior to joining the
division of research,
Dr. Kushi was at
Columbia University
where he held the Ella
McCollum Vahlteich
chair in human nutrition
in the Department
of Health and Behavior
Studies, Teachers College.
And he was a member of the
Herbert Irving Comprehensive
Cancer Center at Columbia
Presbyterian Medical Center.
Dr. Kushi is internationally
recognized for his expertise
in nutritional epidemiology.
And his research interests
focus on the role
of diet and nutrition
in the etiology
of coronary artery disease
and breast and other cancers.
He serves on a grant review
committee for the American
Cancer Society and has served on
various American Cancer Society
committees to develop guidelines
for the dietary prevention
and management of cancer.
Dr. Kushi has also served
on review committees
for the Epidemiology and
Disease Control study
section of the
National Institutes
of Health and the integration
panel of the breast cancer
research program of the US Army
Medical Research and Materiel
Command.
He was formerly the chair
of the food and nutrition
section of the American
Public Health Association
and on the executive
committee of the American
Society of Preventive Oncology.
So trust this guy when it
comes to your long-term health.
Larry Kushi--
LAWRENCE KUSHI:
OK, thank you, Liz.
That was more than I expected.
So in any case, thank you,
Krista, the farm-to-table--
is that what the program is
called-- for the invitation
of-- I've got some slides.
Being an academic sort
of leaning person,
I sort of lean on these
slides presentation.
But don't take that as being any
more formal than anything else.
So why don't we show these?
And then we'll switch back
to showing the panel, OK?
So what's up with protein foods?
OK, I'm going to
zip through these
and not necessarily
spend a lot of time
on any particular thing.
Start off with a little bit
of a disclaimer-- whatever
I say here is not--
doesn't represent
the views of Kaiser Permanente
in any official capacity.
It's just me, OK?
So every five years,
the US government,
the Department of Agriculture
and the Department
of Health and Human
Services, put out
these dietary guidelines.
So this year was the year
that the dietary guidelines
were reissued-- 2010 than
2015, which usually means
around the end of that year.
So this was actually
issued pretty much
in January, early January.
And one of the things
I'll just point out
is that they talk about a
healthy eating pattern, OK?
So here are the major
elements or food groups
that the dietary guidelines say
are part of a healthy eating
pattern.
OK, so one of these things
does not look like the other,
as they say in "Sesame Street."
So which of these things doesn't
quite look like the others?
AUDIENCE: Protein.
LAWRENCE KUSHI:
Protein, yeah, exactly.
So this would be kind of
like-- for those of you--
since we're at Google,
I'll use this analogy.
But this would be kind of
like your smartphone screen
and the different apps.
And it says YouTube,
and sort of Google Maps,
and whatever these things--
and then this thing
says JavaScript or
something like that.
So protein is not a food, OK?
It's not something that we go to
the grocery store and purchase,
you know?
And so why is it there?
It's basically a history
of the US government
and basically combining
animal foods and legumes
into one group.
And so these little
sort of crescents
here come from the
previous graphic
that was used related to the
dietary guidelines, which
is here.
And basically it
does the same thing.
There's that protein group.
OK, so combining these different
foods into the same food group,
does this make any sense?
OK, here's your beautiful Angus
cow, part of the protein food
group, so to speak.
Here are a bunch of legumes,
part of the protein food group.
OK, so do these really look like
they belong in the same food
group?
[LAUGHTER]
Only a nutritional
biochemist would really
think that these two
are the same thing
or are similar enough that
they really should be combined.
So one of the things that is
a key component of why those
don't belong together is
that the meat side of things,
particularly the red
meat and processed meat,
is actually something you
shouldn't be eating a lot of.
Whereas the legumes
are actually something
you should be including
in your diet, something
that you should be eating.
So here's a report that
was published last year
from the International
Agency for Research
on Cancer, which basically
links meat to cancer risk.
It's now a class one carcinogen
as recognized by IARC,
in the same category as
tobacco smoke, asbestos,
et cetera, in terms of being a
clear causal agent for cancer
risk.
Now one of the things
that I've been involved in
is volunteering for the
American Cancer Society
and chairing, in this case,
the last time that they updated
their guidelines for
cancer prevention--
nutrition and physical
activity for cancer prevention.
This is the actual
reference if you're
interested in that,
published in 2002.
But here's basically what
we said on this committee.
We said that there are basically
these four main sort of things
that one could potentially do
for cancer prevention-- achieve
and maintain a healthy
weight, be physically active,
consume a healthy diet with
an emphasis on plant sources,
and limit alcohol
beverage consumption.
So if we look at the
healthy diet portion,
then basically we say things
like limit consumption
of processed and red meat.
Eat at least two and a
half cups of vegetables
and fruit each day.
Choose whole grains
instead of refined grains.
Each one of these statements has
a lot of scientific literature
behind them.
We don't explicitly talk
about legumes there,
but we probably should
next time around.
This is a comparable report
from the World Cancer Research
Fund, which is based
in London in the UK,
and the American Institute
for Cancer Research, which
is based in Washington DC.
This was published in 2007.
And they're going to be
updating this and releasing it
in a couple of years in terms
of their updated guidelines.
So their recommendations
are basically very similar.
They're looking at the same
scientific literature published
around the world.
And so if you look at the last
point on this particular slide,
eat more of a variety
of vegetables, fruits,
whole grains, and
legumes such as beans.
So clearly they
call out legumes,
which we probably should
have, but we didn't.
And they also say limit
consumption of red meats--
so very different
messages for these things
that, at least in the
dietary guidelines,
US dietary guidelines graphic,
are lumped together in the way
that they're talked about.
So let's take a
look at this, OK?
Limit consumption of
processed and red meats.
That's what we said as the
American Cancer Society.
And the World Cancer
Research Fund,
at least in an updated
report specifically related
to colorectal cancer, they
say the evidence is convincing
that these things increase
the risk of colon cancer.
OK, so let's take a
look at this just as one
example of how we and the
World Cancer Research Fund
come up with these sorts
of recommendations.
So in colon cancer,
colon cancer rates
vary tremendously
around the world.
It's like 40-fold difference.
And these are just select
areas around the world.
The top line are
African-American men and women
in the United States, who
have among the highest
rates of colon cancer
around the world.
The third one down is people
of European descent ancestry
in the US-- also very high.
Down below are
like India, Madras
here, Chiang Mai in Thailand,
et cetera-- wide variation
in colon cancer rates.
Now published in 1990 was the
first prospective cohort study,
which means a bunch
of people were
enrolled, in this case nurses.
They were given food
questionnaires 1980.
And then they were followed for
six years and determined who
developed colon
cancer and who didn't.
And so the nurses who reported
eating red meat as a main dish
every single day compared with
those who reported very rarely
eating red meat, they
had a two and a half
fold greater likelihood
of developing colon cancer
over that six year period.
And you can see
the more frequently
the meat was consumed,
the greater the likelihood
of developing colon cancer.
So this is the first such
study designed to look at this.
There were a couple
other studies
of different study design
that provided clues
that this might be going on.
There have now been a couple
dozen of these studies.
So this is a meta analysis
of these perspective studies.
And I'll just say,
here's the conclusion--
"High intake of red
and processed meat
is associated significant
increased risk of colorectal,
colon, and rectal cancers.
The overall evidence
from prospective studies
support limiting red and
processed meat consumption
as one of the dietary
recommendations
for the prevention of
colorectal cancer."
So highly consistent
findings across all
these different studies
that are conducted, not just
in the United States,
which that first one was,
but in Argentina, Australia,
various parts of the United
States, and China, and
Japan, and other places.
So let's look back at sort of
colon cancer trends over time.
Here's India, Mumbai.
There's a cancer registry there.
Very low rates-- continues
to be low as time goes on.
Here's the United States,
Connecticut as an example,
one of the cancer registry.
Again, among the highest
rates in the world,
generally speaking.
These are rates of men.
Let's take a look at
Japan-- very low rates
just back in 1960, now among
the highest rates in the world.
This is Shanghai in China--
similar trends going on
as we saw in Japan,
but delayed a bit.
There are things,
very powerful things
happening in the
world that result
in these changes
in disease rates.
This is with women.
You see the same pattern.
Rates are a little bit lower,
but basically the same pattern.
So in India, of course,
cows are considered
to be sacred at least
in some contexts.
And so you'll often see him
wandering around the city
streets and that type of thing.
The first McDonald's that
was vegetarian was in India,
you know?
So what's been going on in
these other Asian countries that
resulted in this type of change?
Maybe something like this--
not to specifically point
to those golden arches.
One colleague says, you know,
when you see the golden arches,
you're looking at
the pearly gates.
You're not far from
So any case, if we look
at actual food consumption
from the Food and
Agricultural Organization,
then you can see, again,
Japan increasing consumption
of these animal
products, in the US,
very high levels, in India,
very low levels-- directly
parallels these colon
cancer rate trends.
AUDIENCE: And that's
combined [INAUDIBLE]?
LAWRENCE KUSHI: Yeah, it's
all of them combined together.
Because that was the
easiest thing for me
to pull out for the purpose
of this particular slide.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] separate
red meat from these other--
LAWRENCE KUSHI: Yeah, so the
question is, should red meat
be separated out?
Ultimately, yes.
Because the health effects do
differ among different animal
food products.
And red meat is probably, and
processed meat in particular,
is probably the worst thing.
But yeah.
And fish, we probably
should be eating
some on sort of
regular basis if one is
going to eat animal products.
And milk there's a lot
of controversy about,
and same with eggs.
And we can go into some
of that if you want,
even though that's aside
from this whole question
about pulses.
OK, so looking at the
pulse side of things,
this other part of this
protein foods sort of group,
this is an analysis that
we did way back when,
when I was at the faculty of
the University of Minnesota.
And if we look at sort
of the turquoise bars,
people who reported
any tofu or soy intake
had about a 25% reduction
in developing breast cancer
over about a six or seven
year period than people
who didn't report any.
So this is from a study of women
in Iowa, about 40,000 women--
actually about 35,000
in this analysis.
But what's the problem with
doing such a study in the US?
So thanks to people like
Minh Tsai, tofu, et cetera,
is more widely available now.
But in Iowa, less than
3% of these 35,000 women
reported eating any tofu
or soy foods, right?
And so if you actually
want to look at this,
you don't have much power,
as you say, statistical power
to look at it, which is ironic.
Iowa produces tons of soy.
But most of it goes to
feed the pigs, you know?
So Iowa's also a big
pork producing state.
So in order to actually
look at this question,
it's better to go
to a population
where people eat a fair amount.
And there's variation.
So here's a study in Shanghai
that I was involved in.
And you can see that basically,
women who reported more soy
consumption compared
with less soy consumption
had somewhat lower
breast cancer risk,
not statistically
significant, but still there.
This is their soy
intake as reported
when they were adolescents, a
clear relationship-- high soy
intake, lower likelihood
of developing breast cancer
a few decades later.
And there are other studies
that have looked at this.
Here's a meta
analysis, again, of
these various several studies.
This one-- basically,
these dark squares
are the high versus
low relative risk.
If the dark square is on this
side of this vertical line,
then that means that the high
intake results in less breast
cancer than the low intake.
If it's on this
side, then it means
high intake is higher
rates of breast
cancer than the low intake.
But overall when you combine
the results across all of these,
and most of the studies show
higher of soy intake, less
breast cancer, then you've
got this relative risk,
which is here-- 0.71, about a
30% reduction in breast cancer
comparing high soy
intake to low soy intake
across these various studies.
This is the same thing--
studies Western populations,
where there's not much
soy intake being consumed
except in hidden things
like sort of soy lecithin,
and as flavoring, and whatever.
And so there's not
much variation.
You don't see too much.
Anyway, so I'll skip over this.
These are of the same,
sort of another way
of looking at meta analysis,
but conducted by other people.
But soy intake and
other diseases-- this
is from studies
in Shanghai again,
the Shanghai Women's
Health Study,
which has been following
75,000 women in Shanghai
for a number of years.
Decreased likelihood of
cardiovascular disease events,
less diabetes, half
the diabetes rate
of people with high soy
intake versus low soy intake,
less bone fractures-- so a lot
of sort of effects of this.
Now is it the soy per
se or a dietary pattern
that includes soy?
You know, it's a little
hard to disentangle that.
But clearly, dietary
patterns that include regular
consumption of soy foods are
better for you than dietary
patterns that don't.
So as was mentioned earlier,
Year of the Pulses--
that's this year.
The United Nations has
just described that.
So this has also
already been mentioned.
But each one of
these statements,
like our dietary
recommendations,
a lot of literature that
supports each of these--
but pulses are
highly nutritious,
as Liz mentioned,
economically accessible,
contribute to food security,
important health benefits.
I just demonstrated or
pointed to some of them
specifically in the soy context.
But this can be extrapolated
to other arenas as well-- lots
of evidence that legume
intake in general
is great for cardiovascular
disease risk, et cetera,
for lowering risk.
Foster sustainable ag, and
contribute to climate change
mitigation and adaptation,
and promote bio-diversity--
so these are all important.
So when you look at that food
group, it's kind of like, OK,
it's not really an
appropriate food group.
But to the extent that some
parts of it, don't do that.
OK
Cows going to the
slaughterhouse--
they say, my only consolation
is that by eating us,
they're killing themselves.
And that's pork,
the meat of the pig.
It makes an excellent
substitute for tofu.
This is where we should be.
Instead of thinking
about legumes
as a substitute for red meat, it
should be the other way around.
When we go on an airplane,
the default sort of meal
that's-- of course, you don't
get meals anymore domestically.
But internationally, it should
be something that's vegetarian.
And then if you want
to have the meat, that
should be a special meal
option or something like that
rather than the way it is now.
So anyway, we can go into more
detail about other things.
I will say-- I mentioned
this at the last panel
that I participated in with Liz.
But I'll just say
that just recently, I
was at a couple of conferences,
cancer related conferences.
I do cancer research.
I heard Vice President Biden
talking about the cancer
moon-shot, et
cetera, and what we
can do to accelerate
advances in cancer research,
decrease the cancer
burden, et cetera-- a lot
of interest in all
this sort of stuff
that's happening in
cancer centers and stuff.
The work that my other two
colleagues here-- the work
that they're doing is going
to have a much bigger impact
on impacting cancer rates
than those targeted therapies
and other things that are
being-- that lots of money
are going into.
Because they're having a
direct impact on these risk
factors, these
dietary changes, that
will actually result in
impacting cancer rates.
And so it's like, I bow
down to these people.
You know, compared with what I
do, sitting in conference room
or at my desk in a
computer room or whatever
and analyzing data--
anyway, thanks.
And--
[APPLAUSE]
--have them join us.
LIZ CARLISLE: Thank you.
And ask us questions.
I always have lots of
questions of these two.
But yeah--
AUDIENCE: So thank you
so much for being here.
LIZ CARLISLE: Let's make sure
we-- yeah, repeat the question.
So the question is
basically, would this
look different, this red
meat, all of these red meat
statistics, if we weren't in
a concentrated animal feeding
lot but actually working
with pastured meat,
with grass fed meat?
What's the difference?
LAWRENCE KUSHI: So
the direct answer
to that question is,
we don't really know.
Because most of these
types of studies that I do,
these epidemiologic
studies, don't
ask about that type of detail.
But I will say that the fact
that these findings have been
seen consistently
around the world,
in countries which have
different sort of animal
husbandry regulations, maybe not
necessarily how much cows come
from feed lots versus sort of
out in the pasture, range fed,
or whatever.
But the fact that some of the
other practices-- you know,
people often talk about things
like the use of antibiotics
and to help-- low
level antibiotics
to help feed the cows, or
hormone implants, or whatever.
We see similar findings
in Europe or in Japan,
for example, as in the
US where here in the US,
most beef cattle are given
estrogen sort of implants
or estrogen analog implants
like Zeranol or something.
Whereas those same
implants are banned
in those countries because of
potential human health effects.
But we see the same
sort of effect,
which suggests
that it may not be
driven by those specifically.
I mean, they may have
some role on some level.
But it doesn't describe
everything that's going on.
So it doesn't directly
answer your question.
But it does point to the
fact that there-- consistent
finding in different
countries suggest
that it's probably cows.
[LAUGHTER]
LIZ CARLISLE: One
thing that I think
is really interesting to
bring up about pastured meat
and grass fed production is that
if our whole country switched
exclusively to grass
fed production,
we would all eat
a lot less meat.
So that may be the most
powerful health effect.
MINH TSAI: Yeah, I agree.
I think one of the
issues that I see
as a food manufacturer
in the US is
that we have several fascinating
tendency in the United States.
One is whatever we
think it's good,
we tend to just eat a ton of it.
So there's this term moderation.
It's almost lost in
our consciousness.
You know, one of
the reasons we did
Tofu Disrupt from a culinary
side is to say to the public
here that you don't necessarily
have to think of tofu as
strictly a vegetarian food.
Because believe it
or not, in Asia,
it is often eaten with meat.
But it's very proportionate.
The meat is just a
very small portion.
So perhaps portion
control is the answer
here and not necessarily
even tofu, or vegetarian,
or legumes for that matter.
So I think I would be
curious to learn more
about the cases of
Japan, for example,
the quantity consumed and
the frequency of consuming
red meat.
I think they will have
actually a greater impact.
Because I don't
think necessarily
that the Japanese are eating
less tofu necessarily-- maybe.
But I think proportionately,
everything else
they're eating in
greater quantity.
So that's my concern.
LAWRENCE KUSHI:
That's actually right.
The sort of soy food, generally,
sort of consumption Japan
hasn't decreased.
But the meat intake has gone up,
sort of rice intake has dropped
and some other things like that.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: First of all, Minh,
you came here in October.
And you did a really
lovely dish with Chef Liv
where you mixed the ground
tofu and ground pork.
And you had that
same spiel about how
you don't have to replace meat.
But you can flavor
it with those tofu,
and you're already
decreasing meat consumption.
So thank you for
that back in October.
But for Dr. Larry-- correct?
LAWRENCE KUSHI: You
can call me Larry, yep.
AUDIENCE: OK, Larry.
I've done a lot of research on
dietary guidelines globally.
And it's fascinating
how consistent
the world is inconsistent
with these food groups
and how protein, for
example, here how we group
it is very different in
different parts of the world.
But nutrition all comes
from the same science.
So obviously the government
plays a part or food preference
like in India.
And I'm sure you've
seen Switzerland
with their new guidelines.
And they've taken out the
red meat recommendation
and I'm sure have
lower cases of cancer.
And I wonder if the
United States is slowly
moving towards that?
Could you see them pulling out
pulses as their own food groups
or kind of recommending
red meat less and less
these guidelines are updated?
LAWRENCE KUSHI: Yeah,
so there are-- at least
in the US dietary guidelines
context, there are two phases.
There's sort of the
scientifically updated
review that happens.
And then a different
group of people
take those and translate those
into the actual guidelines.
And so that second process--
while the first process
is semi-political in terms of
who gets onto that committee--
different interest groups
nominate various people,
et cetera.
But the work that
they do is largely
sort of apolitical,
sort of review
of the scientific
literature, et cetera.
And so the report that they
put out-- in this case,
it came out a little
over a year ago--
to inform what become
the dietary guidelines is
largely apolitical.
The next step is not, you know?
And so what ultimately becomes
the dietary guidelines,
there are a lot of
competing considerations.
So the US Department
of Agriculture,
as great an organization it
is for a lot of the things
that they do, they
have competing
and contradictory
sort of priorities.
And one is to promote human
health through good food
selection and food
security programs
like the school lunch
program, and food stamps,
and other things like that.
And the other is to help support
the agricultural industry.
And so sometimes--
I mean, way back
when, when we didn't know that
red meat actually was bad,
those didn't
necessarily conflict.
And sort of food security
issues were more paramount
than chronic disease risk.
But now they do conflict in
terms of the overall mission.
And so it's pretty hard for the
USDA to say, eat less red meat.
And in fact the last
time they actually
said that in any sort
of official publication
was in 1979.
They've changed it
to these euphemisms
like choose lean meats or
other things like that.
So they don't-- their
official publications in terms
of guidelines, et cetera,
don't really say that.
But I will say that
generally speaking,
the trend that you are talking
about has been happening.
Because in the last
dietary guidelines
and in the current dietary
guidelines, 2010 and 2015,
they now explicitly recognize
that vegetarian eating
patterns, Mediterranean
eating patterns,
are actually healthful
choices, you know,
that these are not things
that, you know-- I mean,
back when I started studying
nutrition or whatever,
vegetarian sort
of concept of that
was, like, considered to be
sort on the way extreme sort
of wacky sort of thing.
And now even though
people-- there still
aren't large numbers of
vegetarians proportion wise,
it's now considered
to be healthful.
So it's not-- so I think it's--
elements are definitely moving
in that direction.
Yeah.
MINH TSAI: I'll just add
something really quickly.
I don't have the type of
data, scientific data,
that Larry gathers.
But what I've noticed
based on having been around
and making tofu for
more than 10 years
is that with the
advent social media,
of information, that you
guys help foster at Google,
people are just more
knowledgeable about the food
that they consume.
So now it's a matter of
getting that data out
there like the way
Liz and Larry are
doing-- so Liz on the ecological
side, Larry on the health side.
So my job is just to
make it taste good.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, that's the
trifecta right there, right?
So if people can
understand that,
OK, this is the ecological
impact with your decision
when it comes to food.
Larry can give you,
this is a health impact.
And I can tell you,
like, this is great.
Our tofu is amazing.
But don't eat it every day.
You know, eat it
proportionately with other food.
And have a balanced diet.
So I think that's something
that to Larry's point
when he finished is
that's prevention right
there of any form of disease.
So that's what we try
to do as a food company,
as a responsible
food company, too.
So I see the trend in the US
actually being very optimistic
because of information.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming
to talk about the tofu.
I really enjoy
drinking the soy milk.
I've been drinking
it over a year now.
It's a very great
substitute for milk.
And one question
I have for you is
there's couple way
to make soy milk.
One is I saw on your
video you could boil it
and then-- I mean, soak it
with water, and boil it,
and then take the skin
off-- one way to do it.
I think this is
similar to what you
can get in the supermarket
with the unsweetened soy milk.
Another way to do it I saw is
using a blender, a high speed.
And then just run it.
And you drink including the
skin of the milk, of the bean.
One thing I read
on the internet is
about if you eat a lot
the skin of the bean,
it could affect your health.
I like to hear your
thought on that.
MINH TSAI: I'll leave
the health part to Larry.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MINH TSAI: But as far
as making soy milk,
you need to make soy
milk to make tofu.
So as a tofu company, we
make the soy milk first.
And the way we make it
is quite traditional.
And when I mean
traditional, what I mean
is we make it in a way
where we don't waste.
We make it in a way where
we do-- we give respect
to the beans, which means
we actually grind the beans.
And we cook it with the ground
up slurry of the bean itself
for the flavor.
You know, we don't run away
from the flavors of the beans.
Many soy milk you get
in the supermarket
don't have the beany flavors.
I like people to try to really
drink soy milk with that legume
flavors.
Because I think you
can get used to it.
In Asia, soy milk is prized
for that actual fragrance
of the beans.
So I think we'll
get there in time.
And then for me, we also
try to make a soy milk
with high fiber.
I would prefer to actually
leave all that fiber in there.
Because I think it's
actually good for digestion
to have the fiber.
So if you can use a blender
and make it at home,
and you can actually
blend it fine enough
to have the fiber go
through your system,
I think it's healthier.
Now make sure you use organic,
non-GMO soybeans so that-- that
would be what my suggestion is.
But Larry can
chime in and as far
as the health impact of
eating the entire legume.
LAWRENCE KUSHI: It does taste
better with the skin in it.
Yeah.
MINH TSAI: Perfect.
LAWRENCE KUSHI: Yeah.
I just say, you know, that's
probably the better way
to consume it.
But sort of including some tofu
or whatever and other soy foods
that are derived from other
parts of the soybean--
I think that's great.
So as we saw in the video, the
yuba or whatever-- you know,
there are other parts in the
whole sort of soy processing
process.
You could do this all at home.
Actually, we used to
when I was growing up.
We used to make tofu at home.
Because it wasn't
readily available,
except like in the Chinatown.
So you would go to
there or whatever.
And so actually one of the
first tofu companies in the US
was started by some students
of my parents, Nasoya,
which started in Massachusetts
way back when, you know?
And there's others that
sort of grew from that.
But in any case,
it's definitely--
if you can eat
the whole soybean,
even if it's in different
foods, that's great, you know?
If you blend up the soybean, the
whole soybean, as you're making
soy milk, that's great too.
MINH TSAI: So as
far as you know,
there's no long term effect
on health including the--
LAWRENCE KUSHI: So I'm
guessing-- total guess here,
so don't hold me to this.
But I'm guessing that
the suggestion there
might be related to things
like protease inhibitors,
and phytic acid, and some
of these other things
that in theory might
bind some minerals
and sort of inhibit
absorption if you
have more of the outer part
of the soy bean sort of as
part of what you have.
Those things, while there's
some truth to all that,
those things are also
probably some of the reasons
why eating these
products, legumes
in general and whole
grains as well,
are helpful for cardiovascular
disease risk, heart disease
risk.
That's where a lot of the
antioxidant properties
come from.
That's where sort of the
ability to potentially
sort of inhibit--
in the soy context--
inhibit sort of
cell proliferation
or some other things that
probably play a role in cancer.
So overall, I mean, there
may be these individual sort
of possible sort of
negative health effects.
But overall, it probably
actually contributes
to why these are
healthful foods.
MINH TSAI: I'll tell
something funny.
We actually all over the world
eat legumes very similarly.
We actually rehydrate
them often and then
we slow cook them for our
body to actually absorb
all the nutrients of
the beans, whole beans.
Tofu is totally an
accidental discovery.
Somebody was cooking beans
in a pot with excess water
and decided to flavor
it with something
that's acidic, which turns that
protein liquid into a solid.
So if you think about-- I
mean, eating organic carrot
with the peel on is so much more
nutritious than peeling it off,
for example.
So the fact that you're
eating the entire bean,
it's probably good.
AUDIENCE: I hear lots of
concerns around high content
of estrogens.
And I'm not sure is this
in general a concern?
Is it conventional soy
versus organic soy?
Or what are your
thoughts around that?
LAWRENCE KUSHI:
OK, so Minh maybe
has some other ideas,
or maybe Liz too.
[LAUGHTER]
MINH TSAI: I'm not allowed
to speak on this one.
LAWRENCE KUSHI: OK.
So one of the things that
soybeans in particular,
compared with other legumes,
is pretty much sort of known
for, in a sense,
is relatively high
what are called phytoestrogen
content and isoflavones, which
soy beans are
really great source
for, concentrated source
of are phytoestrogens,
meaning that they have
potential estrogenic activity.
So genistein is one
of these isoflavones.
Daidzein is another one.
And there are a couple others
that exist in soy foods,
and also in some other legumes,
as well as some other foods.
OK, so the question
really is, OK,
does consuming these have
a negative health impact?
Now it's clear that if you
take genistein, or daidzein,
or whatever, and you put
it in tissue culture,
and you've got these
cells-- you know,
these MCF-7 cells
or whatever, which
are sort of estrogen-sensitive
breast cancer cells,
then the cells will proliferate.
They've got estrogen
receptors on them.
The isoflavones bind to those.
It causes a cell proliferation.
If you do the same kind of
thing, you take a xenograft
and you stick it on to an
animal or something like that,
and then you give them a
lot of these isoflavones,
that tumor is going to start
growing or whatever, OK?
But what actually happens in
real life in human beings?
As the studies
that I showed you,
breast cancer risk,
which is in fact
related to endogenous
estrogen levels--
if anything, people who are
eating soy on a regular basis
have lower likelihood of
developing breast cancer.
And now there's
three or four studies
that show that women with
breast cancer, including
hormone receptor positive
breast cancer who have more soy
intake compared with the
less-- not going overboard,
but more compared
with less-- they
actually have better prognosis,
lower recurrence rates
and better survival rates.
So this theoretical
sort of concern
that you can demonstrate
in tissue culture
doesn't translate
into what actually
happens in human populations.
And so if anything, eating soy,
including women with hormone
receptor positive
breast cancer, it's
probably-- it's
certainly not something
to avoid that you need
to be concerned about,
despite what a lot
of people say there.
So anyway, that's one sort of
general thing that I'd say.
LIZ CARLISLE: My
lay interpretation
of this data-- and I've been
really interested following
this discussion-- is that it
reinforces this recommendation
that we should eat
whole foods, that there
is some genius in the
combination of compounds
in actual plants that is
destroyed when you isolate
compounds from those
plants and eat them
by themselves, that there's
something very different that
happens when a human
metabolizes that.
LAWRENCE KUSHI: Yeah.
Yeah.
I would agree.
Actually, there's an
upcoming conference
at the National Cancer
Institute next week
about dietary patterns
and where research
should be moving in
terms of really thinking
about the whole
combination of things.
There's this whole concept in
some of the nutrition research
area of food synergy, which
is combinations of nutrients
and different foods
and how that may
be more important
for health than sort
of looking at isolated
individual compounds
like genistein or whatever.
So I think there's
growing recognition
that, yeah, when we
think about these things,
we should sort of
step back and not
focus on individual nutrients
per se or dietary components.
MINH TSAI: And I think,
on a culinary note,
I think whole foods
just taste better.
The least processed
it is, actually,
if you teach people
how to cook with it,
it actually tastes so much
better than processed food.
We eat process food
because we want
to keep it for long shelf life.
We eat processed food because
it's cheaper in many cases.
But many of the
processed food like one
of the-- one of the cheapest
form of processed food
is soy protein isolate.
It's in everything.
But it was never meant
to be a food, you know?
It was supposed to be a paper
coating, a paint coating.
But it was never
meant to be a food.
But some genius thought,
hey, this is super cheap.
And I can add some
flavor to it and turn it
into like mock hot dog.
[LAUGHTER]
So now you have something that's
like $1.99 that is soy food
but is not necessarily as
healthy as eating whole beans,
you know?
So try to eat as little
processed as possible.
Same with meat-- that's why
processed meat, it's up there.
So all right, that's all I'm
going to say about health.
[LAUGHTER]
Because Larry is here.
And on that note, I'm going
to hand it back to Liz.
LIZ CARLISLE: Thank you so
much all of you who are here,
all of you who are here
watching us remotely.
Liz Carlyle, Dr. Lawrence
Kushi, Minh Tsai--
feel free to ask us
questions afterward.
You saw our emails
on the slides.
[APPLAUSE]